good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
yesterday we learned damning new details
about the domestic
spying operation excuse me it catches in
your throat even saying it
the domestic spying operation the obama
administration ran from the white house
against its political enemies
general mike flynn chief among them
today
fallout from netscan we'll have an
update for you in just a minute on that
but first tonight it has been close to
three weeks since the state of georgia
began to gradually loosen
its coronavirus lockdown starting in
late april the state allowed hair salons
bowling alleys barber shops and gyms to
reopen
three days later restaurants and
theaters followed hospitals were once
again allowed to perform
all needed surgeries they could stop
pretending that the coronavirus was the
only medical problem that patients face
it's not there's nothing especially
radical about what georgia did
but you wouldn't know that if you were
watching television that week
the decision was described there as the
most reckless public health
decision since 9 out of 10 family
doctors endorsed camel cigarettes
untold millions would die because
georgia was reopening
the state of georgia would be flattened
by a tidal wave of corpses
it was that dangerous even stacy abrams
took a break from campaigning for vice
president to offer an assessment
we honestly don't understand the mayors
of
our largest cities have all expressed
deep concern
as of our scientists this makes no sense
and it doesn't improve our economy it
simply puts more
georgians at risk yeah she seems to know
what she's talking about
you should know though that stacey
abrams is delusional
at one point she announced that she was
the governor of georgia which from a
mental health standpoint is one step
from claiming you're napoleon
now abrams imagined she is a public
health expert
best to humor her on that just nod and
look interested chris hayes is not a
scientist either he's msnbc's most
ardent male feminist
but he still has strong views on
epidemiology
hayes was so upset by the idea that
people in georgia might go outside
without permission
that he suddenly found himself arguing
that everyone must obey
the trump administration if that sounds
insane to you you're not alone and for
the record
georgia does not meet the white house
guidelines it does not have a 14-day
trajectory of declining cases
it has tested less than 90 000 people
out of a population of more than 10
million
mayors in georgia are describing the
governor's decision
as reckless dangerous and illogical
oh the voice of overpriced brooklyn we
must do what the white house tells us he
screams
on msnbc that's how dangerous it was
mark this day wrote one longtime
washington reporter
because two and three weeks from now the
georgia
death toll is blood on governor brian
kemp's hands
well as it happens we did in fact mark
that day it was april 25th
2020 when the reopenings began that day
georgia had 650 new cases of chronovirus
yesterday which was 18 days later
georgia had a total of
555 cases of coronavirus
infections and death in georgia have
been declining since early
april that's why they began to reopen it
there are still sick people in the state
there will be for a while some of them
will die
but as of tonight george's numbers the
actual numbers
are no worse than the national average
and that tells us a lot we should be
thrilled by this news
because it suggests that america can
begin to return to normal
restore rights stolen from the
population
maybe even treat citizens like adults
once again and
not court medical disaster you would
think our leaders would be racing to the
podium
to share this great news but of course
they're not just the opposite in fact
they're doubling down on
authoritarianism they enjoy
being in total control of your life they
do not plan to relinquish the power they
receive from this pandemic
anytime soon if ever the city of los
angeles for example has extended its
lockdown through the end of july
citizens there will have to wear masks
at all times even when they're outside
where the risk of transmission
is minimal mayor eric garcetti did not
explain the science
behind these commands there isn't any
science instead garcetti told his city
that
until there is a quote cure for the
virus life will
never go back to normal never the mayor
did not mention that it's possible in
fact it's likely that there never will
be a cure for the coronavirus
whatever and suppose you didn't ask
questions about it she just quickly
endorsed
the whole thing there are a lot of
people in los angeles county who are
saying
whoa three more months i can't survive
this as a small business
i can't survive this as someone who's
out of work
well of course i agree with the
decisions of the people on the ground in
their particular
venue and location so yes it's it's
inconvenient
but it's even more inconvenient if
you're going to
be infected or worse yeah
it's inconvenient yeah it's inconvenient
but it's not as inconvenient as getting
infected with a deadly disease says
pelosi
and it's a good talking point by the way
hat tipped to the 26 year old staffer
who wrote it
but as a factual matter it is wrong for
the overwhelming majority of americans
the lockdowns are far worse than getting
sick with the wuhan coronavirus
if you're under 60 the odds of dying
from this virus are fewer than one in a
thousand
probably less than one in ten thousand
the odds meanwhile that government
lockdowns are making you poor and
destroying your life
those chances are far higher than that
ask yourself
how many healthy middle-aged people do
you know who've died from this virus
maybe you know someone how many people
do you know who are now
unemployed and terrified of the future
probably a lot
washington governor jay inslee not a
math guy he's not calculating
probabilities like this
inslee apparently believes that everyone
in washington state
faces the real likelihood of dying from
the virus and that's why he's ordered
officials in the state
to track who goes to restaurants and who
they eat with
because that's not a chinese police
state tactic or anything
this contact tracing obviously if if
you have somebody who's become sick and
they were sitting right next to a person
at a restaurant
to be able to identify that person could
be very valuable
for their health to try to save their
life
and so we put that uh in place
yeah it's kind of weird that the
authorities are taking notes on who
you're having dinner with but you know
it's for the public health so
submit it's not like politicians would
ever misuse that information or anything
so sleep well
and don't forget to send in a blood
sample so the government can sequence
your dna
for public health reasons nobody in
america
is enjoying all of this more than
michigan governor gretchen whitmer it's
always the most mediocre people
who love fascism the most it gives them
power they never dreamed they would have
and indeed don't deserve whitmer wants
this moment to last forever
she's enraged that anyone would dare to
complain about it
she went on abc yesterday and dismissed
any citizen who disagrees with her
needless to say
as a racist and then she promised that
disobedient
citizens in michigan serfs will be
punished with even more severe lockdowns
these have been really political rallies
where people come with confederate flags
and
nazi symbolism and and calling for
violence this is uh racist and
misogynistic and
i ask that everyone who has a platform
uses it to call on people
to observe the best practices
promulgated by the cdc and to stop
encouraging this behavior because it
only makes it
that much more precarious for us to try
to re-engage our economy which
is what everyone says they want us to be
able to do
yeah not only is it racist it's
dangerous to the public health
and racist whitmer was later asked if
she had
evidence proof that protesters were
actually spreading the virus and
you'll be surprised to learn she didn't
and by the way that question is
misogynistic so shut up
bigot some people in michigan are
finally growing tired of this
performance
carl mankey owns a barber shop he would
like to continue cutting hair
authorities won't let him do that they
prefer to send him welfare checks
instead
that is not the country he wants to live
in though
i'm 77 i've always worked
i've never looked for handouts i don't
even know what they are i had
somebody call me and say well why didn't
you get on food stamps
well you know i don't want food stamps i
want to work
when our governor said we you know we're
going to have another 28 days it knocked
me to my knees i i couldn't take another
28 days
all of us as americans need to begin to
take responsibility for ourselves
you know i feel that the the government
is not my mother never has been
right you know and uh matter of fact
this administration for the most part
i've been in business longer than
they've been alive
gretchen whitmer was not amused by that
government is not my mom
misogyny and by the way cutting hair is
racist
so whitmer's administration tried to
shut manky down with a court order
because there's nothing else going on in
michigan right now
a judge resisted that it was too far so
whitmer's lackey simply
revoked monkey's barber's license
now he's shut down for good and will be
even when the lockdowns finally end
that'll show him stop whining and take
your welfare check
bigot this is insanity
obviously and at some point we're going
to look back in shame as we consider it
politicians will always seize the
maximum amount of power they can that's
why they went into politics
in the first place to fill that empty
space inside
the question is for the rest of us why
are the rest of us allowing this to
happen